Hi there, I'm Laura
from the 7 Alliance for International Recruitment
and I'm joined today by Victoria Stone.
Hi there, I work in the Devon Alliance
for International Recruitment team also.
Great. Thanks,
Victoria. So
we've been hearing a lot of buzz online
from our followers that, um,
international recruitment will be stopping
for the NHS by the end of this year.
What do you think about that?
Well, I am pleased to say that the
Devon Alliances stance on international recruitment
is that we are very much continuing.
It is business as usual for us.
The NHS Long Term Workforce Plan
very much supports international recruitment
over the next 10 to 15 years.
So the good news is,
please keep continuing with your applications to us
so we can support you with your dream of becoming
a health care professional here in the UK.
Thanks, Victoria.
So what type of nurses are you looking for?
Oh, we are looking for a range of nurses
including general, medical,
surgical, um,
but also theatre nurses,
uh, particularly an orthopedics, um,
anaesthetics,
uh, and max FAX.
Um, yes, so we are looking for a good spread of general,
medical, surgical
and also theatre nurses
wherever possible,
please. Oh, great.
Thanks very much,
Victoria. Hopefully
that clears up some questions for my followers.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Bye.